-Good luck.
Good luck.
-Now, you all know
how to play charades.
Each player gets a turn
giving silent clues
to their teammate.
30 seconds on the clock
per turn.
We're going to do four rounds,
and in the fifth round --
Do you have a breathing problem?
-What? My breathing?
-They're nervous.
-I know you're breathing...
-I'm terrified.
-...but you're breathing like
[Exhales sharply]
-[ Laughs ]
-You're being weird tonight,
man.
-I'm just getting ready.
[ Laughter ]
-We're going to do four rounds.
The fifth round
is the charades showdown.
Both teams get the same clue
at the same time.
I'll go first.
You guys can all take
your seats.
All right, Tariq,
you're over here with Aaron.
-All right. -
All right, yeah. Who goes first?
I just said I'll go first.
-Jimmy, you're going first.
-That's what I just said?
-Get your head in the game.
-Sorry, here we go.
All right, ready, pal?
-Oh, wow.
-Lets do this.
-Yes.
-All right, ready?
Here we go.
-Okay.
-What number, guys?
[ Audience shouting
suggestions ]
I love there's one guy
who's like, "Three."
All right.
Here you go.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-You got this.
You got this. We are one.
-Yep.
I think we got this.
Ready?
-Movie.
Two words.
First word.
Me? You?
Boy? I?
Second word.
Margo?
"I, Tonya?"
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
You felt that?
-Oh, my God.
How?
-Go.
-How -- Is it me? Oh, God.
-I just watched that.
It's so good.
-That's great.
It's great. Yeah, it was good.
-Oh, no.
-Come on.
-What do you got?
-[ Laughs ]
Ooh. He went straight
for the eight.
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Tariq, he's an actor.
He might be acting.
-I don't think so.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a great face.
-Movie.
Two words.
First word.
Short?
Small? Short? It?
The? Okay.
Second word.
The fist?
The fight?
The fighter?
The boxer?
The -- The claw?
The punch?
The -- The -- The --
-[ Exhales sharply ]
[ Laughter ]
-The claw.
-The -- The knuckle?
The hand?
The punch?
The fist?
The swing?
-[ Laughs ] I like the claw.
-Is it time?
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, my gosh!
-Yes, thank you.
-Dude, you ate it right there.
Tariq, that hopefully --
-"The Wolverine?"
-Ah. Yes.
-Tariq: What?
Wolver-- Dude, you --
-Claws!
-That was pretty good.
-You should have been like,
"More, yes, the claw."
Like -- Like this.
Like --
-Yeah.
-[ Groans ]
-It's okay.
-Well done. Well done.
-I thought it was
"The Punisher."
-I feel like we should get
bonus points...
-Yeah, it's all good.
-...if we guess it.
-Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
-Oh, wow.
-Oh, no. Please.
-Making new rules to your game.
-Come on, pal.
-Okay, what number, guys?
[ Audience shouting
suggestions ]
-Two.
That was a pretty solid two.
-Yep.
-Okay.
Okay.
-Come on, Klossy, we got this.
-Okay.
Okay.
-What is it, though?
One word. It's a movie.
"Titantic."
[ Laughter ]
"Spin?"
Oh, "Twister."
[ Bell dings ]
-Yes! Yes! Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got this.
-Helen Hunt!
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
-Helen Hunt.
-Classic.
-Phew!
-Oh, no.
-Whoomp, there it is.
[ Audience shouting
suggestions ]
I love that you're not
even talking now.
You've already started
to not talk.
-We got this?
Okay.
-Oh, wait. You just said
something with your eyes.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Oh. Oh.
-You just said something
with your eyes to him.
-Okay, song.
-Mm-hmm.
-Little?
Small?
Uh, short?
Tiny?
Tiny.
-Second word.
"Tiny Dancer."
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay. All right. All right.
[ Laughter ]
-That was beautiful.
That was beautiful.
-A new dad move.
-Oh, wow.
-This one is the last round.
Karlie and Aaron, you are going
to be giving the clue,
the same clue,
and whoever guesses first wins.
This is worth 10,000 points.
[ Laughter ]
-10,000? 10,000 points.
-This is it.
This is the game right here.
So you guys go up.
-Okay.
-And you pick
the same clue and you'll --
-Okay.
-We pick the same clue?
-Yeah.
-All right.
Guys, what are you feeling?
[ Audience shouting
suggestions ]
-I hear four.
-Yeah, sure.
-Okay.
Okay.
Yeah? Yeah?
-Yeah.
-Yeah?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, wow.
Okay.
-All right.
-Wait, wait, wait.
On your mark.
I'm very competitive.
Get set, go.
-Three words.
Movie.
First word short.
The?
-At?
-The? At? Okay, the --
-At.
-Halo.
Oh. At Queen?
The Queen?
Royal?
The crown?
-The angel?
-The king?
Prince?
Princess.
At princess?
-The horn.
-Third word.
-"The King's Speech."
-"The Princess Diaries"!
[ Bell dings ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You were right there!
-"Princess Diaries"!
-Oh!
I'm sorry.
-That's my partner right there!
-Oh, wow.
-Whoo!
Whoo.
My thanks to Aaron Paul...
-Wow. Well done. Well done.
-...Karlie Kloss, Tariq Trotter.